so yeah I just wanted to spend a couple
minutes talking about partner developer
relations so we're are your developer
advocates and so we work with partners
hence the term partner developer
relations so partners meaning game
developers like you and so we're all
engineers so we're on the technical side
of things we're not on the business side
of things and all of us pretty much all
of us have worked with game companies
before in the past so we have some
understanding of the difficulties that
you have to go through
we're located around the world in
various locations in North America
amia and AIPAC and as I mentioned we
work closely with partners sometimes we
make visits to partners and actually
work on-site to help with performance or
help debug problems we also have
meetings and emails with partners also
you should consider us your first point
of contact for technical questions
another thing we do is to tell
developers that events such as this
about new technology related to games
from Google and one of the most
important things that we do is gather
feedback from developers on how we can
improve our products so I encourage you
to to all give us as honest feedback on
how you think we can improve and you
know feel free to do it today especially
is a good time it get in you know go
ahead and ask questions or make
suggestions during the meetings today so
one of the things we've been doing
recently is focusing on high fidelity
games and this is because we're seeing
this trend because of the improvement in
mobile hardware that's capable of
running games that you know
traditionally are on consoles or pcs
and thing is it's this really stresses
the system it requires a lot of the
system and so things like Vulcan are
important for rendering to get the most
performance and so one of the things I
did was I looked and see saw how much
how many devices actually support Vulcan
and you can do this by going into the
Play Store in the device catalog and you
can see this about 400 devices it's
probably more now and there's our device
models that support Vulcan and this
turns out to be about 427 million
getting close to half a billion devices
now that support Vulcan now this doesn't
mean all of those devices are capable of
running your game there could be
problems where the hardware isn't fast
enough or there could be problems with
the driver quality so this is something
that you would need to test so as I
mentioned it's these high fidelity games
are really pushing the limits and so we
are job is we want to improve that
ecosystem make things better for
developers of these types of games so
today for example in these sessions
we're going to be talking about Vulcan
Samsung and Crytek are going to be
talking about their experience of
working with Vulcan
and and trying to optimize and then
because these games are more complex and
like a casual game they require good
tools for debugging and profiling and so
we have sessions on Android studio and
kappa'd and systrace these are tools for
debugging and profiling we recognize
that these are important to have and
we're going to continue to improve these
tools also because they're of the wide
variety of devices out there and
capability of devices and driver quality
in testing is very important for these
types of games so we have a session on
automated testing
by Nettie's which should help improve or
improve the time required for testing
and also plural is going to talk about
using device catalog in the play console
for having to helping them to select
which devices to run their games on last
thing I want to mention is we are going
to have office hours this week during IO
Wednesday and Thursday I have a QR code
here if you can grab that this will link
to a site where you can schedule office
hours with us one hour slots also you
can check your email I think I sent out
something about office hours and on the
event website there's a link to it or
you can just talk to me and I'll
schedule something for you
it'll be they'll be held at a building
on Crittenden Lane which is right across
the street from shoreline amphitheater
so not too far from I Oh